Part C right but do not evaluate an
integral expression for the volume of
the solid generated when our so that's
this region right over here when R is
rotated about the horizontal line y is
equal to one so y equals one is right
over there so the way I'd like to think
about it let's think about what the
volume if I were to just take the bottom
function if I were to just take f of X
if I were to just take f of X and if I
were to rotate that function around y
equals x if I were to rotate this thing
around
sorry around Y is equal to one what
would the volume of that be and then I'm
going to subtract from that the volume
if I were to take the top function if I
were to take G of X and rotate it around
so let's first of all think about what
volume I would get and this is really
the disk method and then go into it in
much more detail earlier in the calculus
playlist but let's think about the
volume if f of X is rotated around that
axis and to do that let's imagine each
of each sliver of that volume so this is
let me draw a little thing right over
here and you could imagine once this
little sliver is rotated it forms the
bot it forms that or that you should you
could imagine you could imagine this
length is the radius of a disc and so
and just to imagine that let me draw the
entire disk so if this is rotated around
if this is rotated around it will become
a disc it will become a disc it will
become a disc that looks something like
that
and I'll just call the depth of the disc
so the disc if you imagine it a coin
this is kind of the side of the coin the
depth of the coin the depth of the coin
right over there and I can draw that
better than that let me so the depth of
the coin is just like that it's a fixed
depth and I'm going to call that DX so
it's just this distance right over here
it is DX and what is going to be the
area of that coin well the area of the
surface of this coin so let me let me do
it like this in a different color so I
want to do it in blue the area of this
coin is just pi times the radius of that
coin squared
and what is the radius of the coin well
the radius of the coin is this height is
this height right over here and what is
that height well it is 1 minus f of X so
that is equal to the radius so the area
the surface the area of kind of the face
of this coin is going to be pi the area
of the face of this coin is going to be
pi times the radius squared which is
equal to pi times 1 minus f of X 1 minus
f of x squared that's this blue area
right over here and then if I want to
find the volume of this coin I would
multiply it by the depth of the coin so
x so x DX and if I wanted to find the
volume of this entire solid this entire
rotate' solid I would want to find the
sum of all of these volumes so this is
just the disc right over here but I
could have another disc a similar disc
that I do right over here I could have
another disc right over here and I want
to take the sum of all of those discs so
I want to take I want to take so the
volume is going to be the sum over all
of those discs so X goes from 0 which is
this bounding point to X is equal to 1/2
times pi times 1 minus f of X squared
this is the area of eat the the area of
the face of each of those discs and then
I multiply it times the depth of each of
those discs now this is the volume of
each of those discs and I'm taking the
sum of all of them so this is the volume
this is the volume if I were to just
rotate f of X around y is equal to 1 and
actually I should just write D of DX
here and so this right over here this
expression I just did that - they really
are equal this is obviously just the
volume of each of those discs so this is
a volume if I take the f of X around y
equals 1 let's figure out so let me call
this volume of f of X and by the same
logic the same exact logic we can figure
out the volume if we take G of X if we
rotate G of X around if we rotate G of X
if we construct disks like this and
rotate them around Y is equal to 1
and so the volume if I take G of X
around y equals 1 would be 0 to 1/2
times pi times 1 minus G of X because 1
minus G of X is each of these radiuses
right over here each of these radiuses
that squared DX and so the volume of
what they're asking us the volume of the
solid generated when R is rotated well R
is kind of the space in between f of X
and G of X so it's going to be it's the
volume is going to be the difference
between these volumes it's going to be
this volume it's this is kind of the
outer volume and we're gonna take out
its hollow core we're gonna hollow it
out by subtracting out this volume so
the volume of that region is going to be
the integral I'll do this in a new color
integral from 0 to 1/2 of pi times 1
minus f of x squared DX minus the
integral from 0 to 1/2 of pi times 1
minus G X G of x squared DX and this is
a completely valid answer but you might
want to simplify it we have the same
bounds of integration we have the same
variable of integration and actually we
have this PI over here so we could
factor that out and so this is the same
thing as pi times the integral from 0 to
1/2 of 1 minus f of X 1 minus f of x
squared minus 1 minus G of X 1 minus G
of x squared and then all of that DX and
then an actually you probably would want
to do this you probably would want to do
this if you're taking the AP exam not
just leave it in terms of f of X and G
of X you would actually want to write
the expressions for what f of X f of X
and G of X are so really the best answer
would probably be pi times the integral
from 0 to 1/2 times 1 minus well f of X
is 8x to the 3rd power 8x to the 3rd
power squared minus 1 minus G of X G of
X is sine of PI X that squared that
squared times DX and that would be our
answer and you could see why they didn't
want us to go through the trouble of
evaluating it they just wanted us to set
up this integral